there is a new wrinkle I want to tell
you about in the Donald Trump stormy
Daniels fiasco ton of emails over the
weekends and David you've got to cover
the paternity angle to the Trump stormy
Daniels affair and there is a paternity
angle so far the lines of questioning up
in one Trump's personal hypocrisy right
running on being the guy for the
Religious Right the family man
the good guy despite having had multiple
affairs including with sport porn stars
angle to has been the legality of the
hush money paid to stormy Daniels
possibly coming from campaign funds one
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
which would be illegal angle number
three have been the lies and the
attempts to cover up the payment that
was made but there's maybe a new angle
here and it's being called the paternity
angle and MSNBC's Lawrence O'Donnell
pointed this out on Twitter over the
weekend where he said mr. president why
does your confidentially a
confidentiality agreement with stormy
Daniels forbid her to reveal paternity
information now this is true that the
non-disclosure agreement which we've
seen because it's part of stormy Daniels
recent lawsuit it says she is forbidden
from disclosing both paternity
information and discussing alleged
children stemming from her affair with
Trump so the immediate reaction was this
must relate to a love child that Donald
Trump has or maybe to an abortion that
Donald Trump encouraged stormy Daniels
to have or paid for stormy Daniels to
have but it appears that it's totally
overblown because according to stormy
Daniels own attorney Donald Trump never
impregnated stormy Daniels nor are there
any kids in question here nor any
abortion that took place her lawyer said
in general the stock boilerplate
language for a fair non disclosure hush
money payments includes that you don't
talk about possible impregnation
paternity or any children what kind of a
world do we live in that there is a
boilerplate a fair non-disclosure
contract that includes the provisions
that you can't talk about impregnation
or love children
that may have come from that bottom line
don't believe that there's a kid here
doesn't really make the entire stormy
Daniels thing any less outrageous
overall and I want to mention this is
sort of a good opportunity for me to
mention the real story here isn't that
Trump had an affair with a porn star or
with anybody else that really is Trump's
business
it's the hypocrisy of running as the
candidate for the moral Christians it's
the Christian voters ignoring the
reality of Trump's life because I guess
they prefer Trump son Christianity
rather than Hillary Clinton
it's the cyclone of lies and hypocrisy
and possibly illegal payments that's the
story not that Trump had an affair yeah
I think it's the campaign finance
violations but well yeah I am going to
disagree with you a little bit I don't
think Trump ran as the Family Values
candidate I just think that the
evangelical right adopted him for
whatever reason it's not like he was
talking so much about you know fidelity
and but hold on a suppor Shin all that
stuff too much Trump chose to say that
his favorite book is the Bible yeah in
thean it's clearly not true that's a
choice he made he didn't need to do that
for the evangelicals to say this is
gonna be our guy instead of Ted Cruz or
whoever else I think you're right that
because if their hatred for Hillary
Clinton and just like the propaganda
around voting for Democrats there were
people on the right who just said we're
gonna adopt this guy cuz he's the
Republican but Trump was pandering as
well a little bit I don't think he ever
made the best case I just think that the
evangelicals were eager to adopt someone
other than Hillary yeah and they liked
his personality I guess yeah I think
there's probably plenty of plenty of
blame or responsibility to go around
depending on which words you want to use
today's program is sponsored in part by
custom menswear line endowed Chino I
went to endowed chinos Boston store
storefront and worked with Chris who
made took all sorts of measurements of
me not those get your mind out of the
gutter but all sorts of relevant
measurements for fitting a suit to me
and I came away with a really really
great suit and if your suit doesn't fit
right it's just not going to look good
and Indo Chino is the largest custom
apparel company making not
suits but also shirts to your exact
measurement you basically pick your
fabric you choose your customizations
you either go into one of their
locations to get measured or you can
submit your measurements online if you
don't live near an Indo Chino store the
order is placed and then within three
weeks or even sooner you get a great
custom-made suit made to measure
you can shop online at Indo Chino
dot-com you can go to any of their
showrooms across north america and this
week our listeners and our viewers can
get any premium Indo Chino suit for just
359 at Indo Chino comm when you enter
the code Pakman at checkout
I'm gonna get myself a light tan suit
suit that's what I've always been
lacking and I want to look good at those
summer weddings many of which I've got
coming up so that's my plan for my next
suit that is over 50% off the regular
price for a premium made-to-measure
suits shipping is free
you just go to Indo Chino com promo code
is pakman PA que ma n to get any premium
suit for 359 bucks plus free shipping